taking music reggae music you make this
freaking use fake news the deliberate
spread of false information for
political purposes opinions on how to
tackle the issue vary wildly but there's
one thing the European Parliament
doesn't want we invented el ministerio
de la verità d George Orwell no one
wants the Ministry of Truth in San
husband is they are here jack the u.s.
elections showed the political power of
misinformation and some have pointed
fingers at Moscow you for watching
evocative over de creme the prodi-g you
maharaja eros cooney resolution likely
to be on the radar russia's immediate
neighbors the Western Balkans as well as
France and Germany with elections coming
up another issue up for debate is how to
tackle hate beach online should it be up
to users to behave themselves protect
Giants to enforce the law the code of
contact is investigation by religious
states to Priestley's allottees savini
no technology is qualified to make the
difficult decisions needed to qualify
hate speech six out of ten news items
shared on social media have not been
read by the user sharing it so before
you post this video make sure its real
[Music]